for
okay
folks how many of you are traveling next
week
just remember to take your DCF with
you Beach Bar wherever you are now it's
work on
evaluation nothing else the Tesla
valuation is a good conversation piece
right everybody's interested in Tesla
they're going to be impressed that you
can actually value the company so you
know do with it whatever you want So
today we're going to talk about first
declining companies and we're going to
move on to other aspects of different
difficult to Value companies but before
I do that I'm going to lead in with a
startup where I'm going to ask you
questions about valuing Banks okay when
you look at Banks and you look at the
regulatory Capital some banks are
conservatively financed which means have
a higher regulatory Capital ratio than
is required of them they're safe they're
safe Banks and you're trying to decide
where to reward them with this okay so
let's look at out you know if a company
is conservatively capitalize there's a
lot more Equity than it needs to what
should you expect to see in the
company's fundamentals a high return in
equity low risk low return Equity low
risk High return Equity high risk or low
return Equity high risk what do you
think so let's pause right there why low
return
Equity it's because you're holding a lot
more Equity than you need right so
you're going to learn lower return
Equity that's a bad thing but to off
said it you also will be lower which
means you have to give them a lower cost
of equity one of the things we're going
to talk about today is how do you reward
a bank that is over capitalized how do
you low come up with the lower cost of
effect what we talk about different ways
of doing that the second is let's say
you value a company and most of you
should be getting closer to that number
of your
company and you feel certain about your
value for the company I don't know how
you got that certainty but let's say you
are certain right it's higher than the
stock price so you go go put your money
in would you should you put all your
money in it after all you
certain what part are you not certain
about
that so there are two halves to this
right one is how certain are you about
your value what's the other half how
certain are you that price will adjust
to Value if you're certain about both of
course you should put your money in all
your money in one company but I have a p
on concentration versus diversification
because there is a big argument among
investors should you spread your bets
across 20 25 30 companies or put all
your money in four or five companies and
there are very lots of big names that
come down in the four or five companies
now Mark Cuban for instance argues you
should concentrate your portfolio and go
for the big Winners and that spreading
your bets is a sign that you lack
conviction that's a that's a word that
they use you lack conviction so I wrote
a piece on concentrate was a
diversification was not about showing
one is better than the other I said
where you fall in this Continuum will
depend on two things how certain you
feel about your valuation and how
certain you feel that price will adjust
value if you're absolutely certain at
one end of the Continuum you can put all
your money in one stock but the less
certain you feel about one or both the
more stocks you need in your
portfolio and it led me to an
implication which is today you need more
stocks to spread your bets than you did
20 30 40 years ago why because the world
has become more uncertain globalization
has played its its magic and now there
are very few companies where you can
feel certain about what you're going to
get so we're going to deal with those as
we go through but let me go back to
where we left off and I'm going to start
with any questions you might have
because some of you might be valuing
young companies might have chosen to
revisit those valuations after last
class are there any question because we
talked about young companies we talked
about mature companies where you can
bifurcate and either do the status quo
but are there any questions about young
or mature companies
yes is it when they will get mature what
they will look like but
they can can you be a little more
specific give me what you're thinking
about because the abstract I can't
really answer so give me an example of a
young company where you really are
uncertain about
this
yeah but you also told me the market is
a niche market it's not growing that
much so in the market itself act as a
kind of a restrictor and how long you
can continue this right it's more
difficult we have a young company in a
market that's changing and evolving and
growing because then you can say look
the market could be three trillion it
could be 300 billion I think the market
will act as a cap on how long you can
let this company grow so I'd watch the
revenues year one year two year three
and at some point you got to say I'm
already 60% of the market if the market
doesn't keep growing I'm going to hit a
cap so let the market kind of act as a
know any other questions so the third
group of companies I want to talk about
are declining and distress companies and
as I mentioned up front they're
depressing to Value because the story
you're telling is not an upbeat story so
let's take each to the questions when
you look at a declining or distressed
company when you look at the existing
cash flows you look at the history what
do you see revenues are decreasing not
increasing margins Under
Pressure there's no happy talking often
there's CEO changes take a look at Intel
and Starbucks and Walgreens right I mean
there's know all three companies once
once were glorious companies but now
have fallen in hard times when I ask you
what's the value of growth you start
laughing what grow that was 10 years ago
now you're looking to say how do I
shrink rather than grow how risky will
you be your entire business can change
depending on what you're divesting and
shutting down and what you keep and what
you do with your debt and ask you when
will you be a mature company it's like
going into a senior home and say when
will you be
middle-aged they say what I'm 83 years
old how the heck do I get back to being
middle-aged it's in the
past so I'm going to take an example of
a declining company and talk about
valuing the company you're going to see
much of the same mechanics that you see
with the traditional company but you're
going to see psychologically why it's so
much more of a challenge you familiar
with Bed Bath and Beyond how many of you
have never been in a Bed Bath and Beyond
you've never been in one okay you've
saved yourself a host of misery okay but
when when I say Bed Bath and Beyond what
do you expect to see when you walk into
the store see the first time I walked in
bed and bath you expect like sheets and
towels and maybe little rugs for the
bathroom you walk into a Bed Bath and
Beyond it doesn't look anything like
what you expected it to it's basically a
department store gone crazy you walk in
say what that's a refrigerator right
there which bedroom or bathroom am I
going to put that in it's basically a
bunch of gadgets and there's all kinds
of stuff what they're hoping is impulse
buing that on your way to buy the
sheets you buy all this other crap you
don't need that's why they target
students college students were a prime
audience for them they' put Bed Bath and
Beyond next to colleges and invite you
to come in and you walk back to your
dorm room with everything except all the
things you actually needed you said
sheets oh my God I forgot towels I
didn't get that either but I've got all
this neat stuff for my table and this
bed this lamp that I bought know looks
really
neat but for a while it was a hot retail
concept I used to live in New Jersey I
no longer do and um I used to live about
10 miles away from the Springfield Bed
Bath and Beyond that was the original
Bed Bath and Beyond so if you want to
make this a destination like people go
to the last Blockbuster video that's
still out there it's like a you can go
visit the original bed bath and be on
because it's dead and gone now but this
was before it died three years ago I sat
down to Value Bed Bath and Beyond
started thinking about what kind of
story can I tell it's a store that
nobody wants to visit anymore because
it's not that know world of online
retailing where you can buy stuff on
Amazon this is not the place you want to
go so the number of people coming to the
store is dropped off but at the same
time there is a score Market where who
likes this concept don't ask me why who
like this kind of store so in my story
here's what I told I told a story of a
shrinking company if you look at my
Revenue growth rate no so when you you
see me project the numbers out you're
going to see a negative growth rate that
said though when you value a declining
company you got to take a point of view
is who's running the company if you
truly are in a declining business and
you're a good manager what should your
pathway be in the company what should
you be trying to
do maybe make your company shorter
smaller liquidate might not be an option
but you want to make your company
smaller you want to focus in on the
places where you can still make money
and that's what good managers do what
happens if I put a Visionary at the top
of a declining
company they basically try to recreate
themselves right they'll do Acquisitions
an amazing thing most of the
time five years later they say that
didn't work in5 billion later you can
already see when you look at declining
companies you don't want a Visionary you
don't want Steve
Jobs at the top of the company you want
Larry the Liquidator know somebody just
says I'm going to shrink the business in
the case of Bed Bath and Beyond I assume
that there would not be a Visionary and
that revenues would shrink 10% next year
so you can see it's not an upbeat story
and they would keep
shrinking for the next few years here's
the upbeat part of the story or
optimistic part I thought in my story
after they' shrunk enough to about half
their size they could preserve
themselves as a niche business where
people who still like this concept could
come in so I make the company smaller
I give them a decent margin you saying
how can the margins improved if you're a
retailer and you're shutting down stores
which stores do you shut down
first your most Capital intensive least
profitable stores right so if you follow
that that that pathway eventually you're
going to end up with your best stores
the stores and locations where people
come in in my story that's what I see as
the end game so company gets smaller and
one more thing as it shrinks you notice
that my reinvestment is a negative
number
you saying what does that mean what is
shrinking mean you're shutting stores
down you're getting out of leases the
less or is often paying you to leave
right cuz you got lease that's actually
the reverse of putting money back into a
company you're taking money out of the
company in some cases you might get
nothing as you shrink in this case I'm
assuming they're going to get some cash
flows so at least within my story the
company gets smaller it shuts down some
stores it gets some cash flows from it
it ends up in the steady state which a
smaller company that can make money I
come up with the terminal
value but there's one final stop once I
get the value of the equity which was
3.34 billion I had to stop and ask is
there a chance that my company will not
make
it Bed Bath and Beyond 3 years ago is
there a chance
absolutely how did I estimate that
likelihood I got lucky Bed Bath and
Beyond had a bond rating of I think B+
it's a well below investment grade and
if you have a bond rating if you go to
SNP or mood Moody's website side they
actually estimate the likelihood that a
bond Will Survive and pay off based on
the bond ratings class AAA bonds
99.9% chance it will make it to your 10
Double B 96% single B 93% but as you go
down the rating class you're going to
see a greater and greater chance of
failure and you're looking at you know
their actual rating the probability of
failure it looks too precise it's
because I'm reading it right off the S&P
table for 10 years so 24% chance that
they will not make it if they don't make
it what will happen they get liquidated
for what whatever assets they have right
might be real estate might be something
else the equity value that I get will be
far smaller if that happens I take an
expected value the value per share that
I got for Bed Bath and Beyond on the
date that I valued it was
$323 the stock was trading at
879 when you think about what I'm doing
here mechanically I'm doing exactly what
I'm doing with a growing company right
the only difference is I'm using a
negative growth rate he saying what's
the big deal know last year or two years
ago I was actually in front of a group
of appraisers who not 30 40 years in the
appraisal business valueing companies so
I asked them a question I said when was
the last time any of you in this
room valued a company and gave it a
negative growth rate and revenues you
know what the answer was
never which is strange right because the
actual companies how come you never run
into them which means that it's
psychological people hate to put a
negative number try it in your
spreadsheet it's almost like your hand
will hold back no you can't do that it
just it seems almost unnatural to give a
company negative growth rate but you got
to get over that with the cining
companies
yes you could if you're ring the
question was can you put in a negative
growth rate in perpetuity right what
kinds of companies would you put a
negative growth rate in perpetuity
in a company whose business is actually
profitable but it's going to shrink over
time fill in the blanks what
what maybe an oil company if you're a
believer in climate change and that
climate change is going to read
restrictions what
else bookstores are dead and gone right
so in a sense they're they're they're
they they're but any kind of declining
Tobacco Company right let's face it
fewer people
smoke and they're getting older and in a
sense a business is going to shrink
unless they decide to go into vaping or
cannabis or whatever the natural
extension is of the tobacco business you
can have negative growth rate in
perpetuity so instead of liquidation you
just make them shrink and go
away
yep where in my cost of capital that I
includeed okay that's a good question
how do we come up with the cost of debt
we look at the default spread a yield to
maturity you know how the yield to
maturity is computed it's by assuming
you pay your coupons and face value all
the way through and taking an IR in
other words a yield to maturity actually
is you staying as a going concern it's a
spread at charge as a bond holder
assuming you make it and make my
payments
no because if I stay and make my
payments I'm not going to go bankrupt
you know what you'd actually have to do
is a cost of debt you'd have to estimate
a likelihood that I will not pay you and
the default spread you'll be using will
reflect an expected payout on your bond
that number will be much much higher
than what you see as a default
spread so it's really difficult to
adjust the discount rate for default
risk because it was not meant for it
costs of capital were meant as discount
rates for going concerned so when people
said didn't I already bring it into the
cost of capital take the numbers cost of
equity cost of debt and you play it
through and it turns out the way we
adjust cost of equity and cost of debt
is for going concerned risk not for
truncation risk the risk you will not
make it in fact that's why when a value
trouble companies sometimes I use the
cost cap for healthy companies in the
business valued and then bring in the
failure risk separately CU getting the
cost of capital trouble company actually
leads you to some very contradictory you
put a 90% debt ratio it turns out you
can end up with a cost of capital
actually lower than the cost of capital
for a healthy company because you're
understating the cost of equity and the
cost of De
yes because I know the rating if I know
the rating and bonds have been rid for a
while S&P and Moody every year do this
updated table where they take the
ratings from 10 years ago and they look
at what percentage of bonds within each
class defaulted so if I know the rating
for a company I can use that table to
estimate a probability of
default let's extend this though in
general when you value a distress
company even if you do everything right
and fix it on your spreadsheet right you
know what I mean fixing it on
spreadsheet you make the low margins
into high margins the debt ratio goes
from high debt ratio to sustainable debt
ratio and you come up with the value
even if you've done everything
reasonably you will overvalue distress
companies because you haven't facted in
the very real chance that they will not
make it so you almost have an add-on
after you've done with the DCF you have
to estimate the likelihood you will not
make it and what you as an equity
investor will collect if that happens so
I'm going to do a second example where
distress was a real danger hanging over
me we heard of Las Vegas
Sans it's a casino company and I'm going
to make a general statement about Casino
companies that I probably should make
but I will make anyway Casino companies
tend to be run by
megalomaniacs there's something about
Casino companies that draws a very
special character Steve
wi now wind Resorts you take all of
them there's there's a reason I bring
that because that's part of the story
Las Vegas s was run by a guy called
Sheldon
adelon it's a publicly traded company
but he owned 52% of the shares in the
company and in the early part of the
2000s it was on fastest growing Casino
companies in the
world it built a casino in Singapore
called Las Vegas you know sand basically
it this uh uh it looks like a ship it's
the most you know strangest building
ever big ship on top of this 25 story
building Singapore then they built a a
casino in maau Casino in
Vegas and casinos if you ever been to
Vegas are hugely expensive deals right
bajio I don't even know 26 restaurants
in there you can get lost in the
building hundreds of millions of dollars
so it cost a lot of money now two ways
you can raise Capital right you can
borrow money or raise Equity Las Vegas
SS consistently borrowed money it's not
a loan cuz you know comp he's saying why
what did I say Sheldon nson own 52% of
the company right when you issue shares
what do you risk that the 52% will drop
below 50% you will lose control if
you're a megalomaniac you don't want to
lose control so they borrowed money
built another casino did this over and
over and as long as times were good
people look the other
way at 2007 one of the most highly
touted stocks on Wall Street and then
2008 hits and the bottom falls out on
two Dimensions one is people stop coming
to casinos because they didn't have any
money and the second was that that debt
that was hanging out there all of a
sudden became a clear and present danger
there was a chance that they could go
bankrupt so this was a valuation I did
of Las Vegas Sands in February 2009 when
rumors were swirling around that the
company wouldn't make it through the
next 6 months I shut my ears to the
rumors I put my Optimist hat on and I
fixed the company in my spreadsheet by
doing what improving margins making the
company profitable reducing the debt
ratio essentially to a healthy level so
by the time I get to year 10 I fixed Las
Vegas s on my spreadsheet made it a
healthy Casino given it a big ter value
discounted all back to the present and
came up with the value per share of
$812 so ask me the
question so I've come up with the value
of 812 stock is at
425 did I buy and I said I was not even
tempted which led to some soul searching
right my what am I missing in the a12
that's the value if Las Vegas s fixes
itself and becomes healthy what are the
rumors swirling around they might not
make it and I haven't factored it in yet
and this is why I think if you look at
disc the cost of capital I did use a
high cost of debt and the debt ratio but
my cost of capital is barely different
from that of a typical Casino company
even with that end so here's what I did
I estimate the probity of distress in
one of two ways one is the way I did for
Bed Bath and Beyond where I took the
rating and based on the rating of B+ I
came up with the 28.25 per chance that
they would not make it
but then you're trusting the ratings
agency to get this right so I tried a
second approach and this came from the
bond market Last Vegas s had bonds that
were trade there were seven new bonds
that were trading at 529 you know
corporate Bonds in the US are issued
with a power value of a th000 right when
you're trading at 529 what's the bond
market telling you there's a great
chance you will not make it I'm actually
going to use the bond price to extract
the probability of default and here's
how I'm going to do it I know the price
of the bond I know the promised coupons
in cash value promised but not expected
right they're promise that's part of the
I take the coupons and cash and I
multiply by the probability that the
company will be around to make that
coupon payment and make that face
value I don't know it yet but I you know
I know the price I know the coupons the
face value and if I've adjusted the cash
flows for risk I can discount back at
the risk free rate so it's a very
different way of pricing a bond instead
of taking the promise coupon and doing
this you know yield to maturity cost of
debt I'm taking the expected coupons in
the face value and discounting back at
the risk
free it's one equation one unknown it's
a little messy but use the solve of a
function in Excel the number I came back
with is 13.5% he's saying what does that
even mean based on the pricing of the
bonds there a 135% chance every year
that I will not make it I need to make
it 10 years right if you take the 30%
chance of failure every year it it turns
out that the probability that I will
make it to year 10 and get to the
terminal value is only 23% the remaining
77% of the time I'm done I'm bankrupt in
which case what do I have to do sell
casinos take the cash flows pay down the
debt and hope and pray there's some
Equity left over and I can almost
guarantee you that if Las Vegas Sans
goes bankrupt your Equity will be worth
nothing
why no first you got to sell the casinos
right how many people are there out
there who are potential
buyers a handful they're all in trouble
with you at the same time you're not
going to find a lot of buyers you're
going to have to Discount the value get
well below what you thought you could
get and you can almost guarantee you're
not going to cover the debt the equity
value is going to be worth zero my
expected value if I use the rating space
property is
$583 if I use the bond market property
it's
a192 with if any of you willing to
stress companies the
DCF one of the inputs I ask you for in
that Ginsu spreadsheet is a failure risk
properity the default is set to
zero but if you have a distressed
company you might want to revisit that
number and put in a likelihood your
company will not make it based at least
on a rating for your company if you have
a lot of debt and that's something you
want to factor in so it's a way of
adjusting the value for the fact that
you won't make
it because the cash flows now risk
adjusted right I'm taking the coupon and
multiplying it with the likelihood
you'll be around to make the payment if
I remember we talked about certainty
equivalent cash flows start I'm
adjusting the cash flows for the risk in
which case I can use the risk free rate
so usually we price bonds by taking the
promise coupons and the face value by a
risk adjusted rate I'm just moving into
the numerator because I want estimate
you're saying are you trusting the bond
market to get the default risk right yes
because I think that's all they're
focused on Equity guys get a little
distracted Ed by all kinds of stuff you
got to give bond market investors credit
they're focused just on one thing will I
get paid will I get paid will I get paid
and hopefully they get it better than
Equity investors
do
yes on this slide so you're saying the
529 price of the bond only accounts for
the risk of gr concern and not
transation risk it reflects what the
bond markets are right so in a sense if
I use a traditional yield to maturity
which is what I do for the default
spread how do I get the yield to
maturity I take the coupons and the face
value so there's nothing no adjustment
in the numerator and then I solve for an
irr that makes my present value what I
get then is a default spread assuming I
get those cash flows right so that's
that's exactly why the you that's why
when I get a default spread for a bond
it's not capturing the risk I will not
make it it's capturing the fact that as
a bond holder my stomach is going to be
rocking and rolling for the next 10
years but I still get paid at the end so
that's part of what bringing in the
likelihood of failure brings in is I
might not make it to your 10 you might
never see the face value and I'm trying
to factor out what the probability
is ex exactly no it's not that wouldn't
be it be lower it would be that if I use
the actual expected cash flows and I
computed my expected return what I get
would be much much higher than what you
compute as the yield to maturity in the
bond so those default spreads we're
using from yields to maturity capture
only the going concern part if I truly
wanted a cost to debt adjust for default
R it's going to pop towards Infinity
just before default because I'm not
going to get paid right so that's why
cost of capital don't work very well
they're never intended for that kind of
risk let's talk about Emerging Market
companies yes question back there
no let's say you're looking at an
Emerging Market company let's go to
question what are your cash flows from
existing assets when I show you a
numbers those numbers whether you like
it or not are going to be colored by how
the economy you're in is doing right you
saying isn't that always the case yes
but in Emerging Markets where the
economies can go up and down you can be
up 20% down
15% everything in in your numbers will
reflect what the country is doing so the
country is going to become part of the
story if you're looking at an Emerging
Market company in addition and this is
not a it's a broad sweep but corporate
governance in many Emerging Market
companies is far weaker than in domestic
Market companies at least us companies
now again it's it's dis diverges across
companies when you look at growth rates
and and risk the growth rates and risk
for an Emerging Market company have as
much to do what the company does as much
as the country if Vietnam is growing 10%
a year in real terms almost every
Vietnamese company is going to get that
updraft in the growth rate and and a
lowering of risk so how your country is
doing affects both what the value of
growth is and how risky you are and
finally when you talk about mature
companies the country truly goes to hell
in a hand basket that can very quickly
end the life of even a stable mature
company aren't too many Venezuelan
companies Left Right 10 years ago you
could probably listed mature businesses
many have gone under through no fault of
their own so here are the things I want
you to think about when you look at
Emerging Market companies the country is
a central player in this game and
somehow you got to bring that country
risk into evaluation we've already
talked about how to do that but my
recommendation is use a
scalpel rather than a carving knife or a
bludgeon what does that mean you have to
think about where to bring in the
country risk and also be be careful
about how much you appli it across
different companies in a country if you
remember the way we computed Equity risk
BR country looked at where you do
business so when you look at a company
we don't just automatically punish every
Brazilian company we look at where you
get Revenue so the whole idea of
computing weighted average Equity risk
premiums and bringing in where you
operate was to apply the scalpel most
people use bludgeons which means all
Brazilian companies all Indian companies
all Chinese company will be punished
because they view the country as risky
second the currency you choose to value
a company and should not matter somebody
remind me again why currency shouldn't
matter and and through what vehicle do
both
change what's a vehicle that currencies
it's inflation right inflation comes in
so you pick a higher inflation currency
your discount rates will go up your cash
flows will go up you bring a lower
inflation currency so I told the value
for a company should not be affected by
what currency you choose and people
don't believe me on this one they said
right so I'm going to show you valuation
of a company called infosis an Indian
company a few years ago I first valued
in Indian
rupees and 5 minutes after I finished my
Indian rupe valuation I chose to Value
it in US my Indian rupee valuation for
infosis gave me a value per share of 614
rupees per share cost of capital growth
rate traditional valuation so then I
switch my valuation to US Dollars and
I'll give you the good news first when I
value infosis in Indian in US Dollars
the cost of capital I get is much lower
since they 12.5% I'm using 9.25 instead
of 10.39 I use that's good news right
lower discount rate but the growth rates
I use are also lower why for exactly the
same reason that my cost of capital is
lower it's because inflation is lower I
have lower cost of capital lower growth
rate bottom line is the value per share
that I got for info say with entirely US
dollar numbers was
$12.7 which converted at the exchange
rate on that day would have given me
exactly the same value per share as
doing everything in
rupees I mean so if you're valuing a
company don't valued in three currencies
and do them sloppily in all three and at
one point in time when you walked in I
don't know whether this is still true
walked into the main C Business School
building The Graduate building there
were five clocks there and they were all
wrong
and I remember going know walking up
with f officer Fraser who I've known for
30 years said can you he didn't have the
control over this I can you take four of
the clocks down and leave one that at
least tries to get the right time what
are you trying to do and this were not
five different times based in five
different time on they were all claiming
to be in New York time with five
different times I think they were just
doing it to confuse people or maybe it's
a business school lesson I missed that
time is a construct my son keeps telling
me this time is a construct so what the
heck does that even mean he used to do
his excuse every time homework was due
at Yale he would miss his homework date
and I'd say Kieran what are you doing
get your stuff in and time he said Dad
time is a construct I said okay maybe in
Yale time is a construct but in the rest
of the world there is a clock that's
taking so now if you're going to pick a
currency pick one just do it right in
that
currency third there is this corporate
governance issue and we talk part
especially about this last session as
the start of the class you know when you
value a company you're worried about
where do I bring in Weak corporate
governance but if you did the valuation
you embedded the bad Management in your
cash flows already so if you're saying
should I discount the value that I get
for a company with bad corporate
governance I think we concluded that you
should not because your cash flows
already reflected so I'm going to give
you an example it's a company called
tube Investments most of you have not
heard it's a South Indian company it's a
long history so whenever I go back to to
Chennai which is where I grew up it's
been long time so I've left but I go
back to visit my par my what was then my
parents and my brother and sister now
it's just my people somehow get when
that I'm coming and I start getting
these
invitations to come in and talk to
companies about the valuation I usually
avoid them like the plague I act like I
don't check my email but this was
actually in invitation the CEO of this
company I known since I was 7 years old
so it's not like I could just blow him
off he said can you come in and talk to
our company about because he was
concerned that the market was
underpricing his company three times
earnings he say I don't know what's
going on where a fast growing company
the market seems to be punishing us so I
said okay I'll come in so I'm going to
take you through the valuation I want
you to tell me why you think the market
is doing what it is it's a company that
is reinvesting a lot that's good right
they're reinvesting a lot they're
reinvesting let's say 60% of their
earnings on average over time they're
earning 99.2% that's not bad right but
this was a valuation in rupees in 2000
when the risk free rate was TW you know
you can see
12% the cost of capital was
16.9% they're growing they're
reinvesting a lot taking projects ear
99.2% and the cost of and there's no end
game here where they're going to move
towards their cost of capital because
they didn't think they had a problem
they said we're making money we're
growing why aren't we getting rewarded
for that growth so you can probably tell
the CEO what I what I told him what's
going on
here basically they're earning a return
on Capital that is well below their cost
of capital and they're on steroids they
keep taking more
projects and they're wondering why their
value is not going up and in fact the
fact faster they try to grow the less
valuable they
become so you asked me what should I
do tell him what he should do send your
project team home stop looking for new
Investments stick with what you have
you'll be worth about 50% more than with
all this trying that you're doing to
grow why because you're earning less
than the cost of capital you're actually
destroying values of growing if I made
the reinvestment rate
0% you know what will happen to my value
per share instead being 62 rupees per
share it becomes 100 rupees per share
the more they try to grow the more value
they're destroying and the reason is
because they're earning a return less
than the cost of capital you're saying
where do corporate governance come in
here if you have a US company that does
this and K I can notices what
happens you get
targeted you can you're forced to right
stop investing these are terrible
Investments it's a family group company
there's zero corporate governance to
worry about they don't think they have a
problem they keep patting each other on
the back saying we're growing we're
making money what's the problem the
problem is you're not making enough
money to cover your cost of capital
growing will only destroy value so with
Emerging Market companies sometimes you
can see them locked in this death dance
basically they're earning less than the
cost of capital but they're growing and
there's nothing that stops them from
continuing to do this which means even
in your terminal value you're setting
the return on Capital below the cost of
capital which means you put any growth
into your terminal value calculation
actually makes your value lower that is
the cost of corporate
governance so finally the question I
asked was what can we
do to fix this I said I'm looking around
the table and every person around the
table seems to have the same last
name I think you need to let go you need
to bring in people from outside because
sometimes family group companies get
locked into this this dance tube
Investments has fixed a lot of its
problems since I think they've become
more professional change the way they
think about things but it requires a
mindset shift right making money is not
enough you got to make enough money to
cover the capital you invested and
enough money to cover your cost of
capital that's a much higher threshold
to meet so think corporate governance
think about how it plays out over
time cross Holdings right not just
Emerging Market company but bigger issue
with Emerging Market companies and we
talked about the problems cross Holdings
is it accounting issue and to that those
gymnastics you got to go through to deal
with minority Holdings and majority
Holdings and just to show you how big an
issue it be I'm going to stay with my
Indian example and the tataa family
group and take three companies all part
of the tataa group Tata chemical I'm say
four companies tart chemicals T Steel
tart Motors and T Consulting Services I
value all three companies see the blue
part that's actually the value that I
got by discounting free cash of the firm
at the cost of capital see the red part
that's a cross Holdings in each of these
companies and in most of these companies
I really know very little about the
cross Holdings so chemicals
steel and Motors gets a get a
significant portion of value from Cross
Holdings but TCS gets a much smaller
percentage I want somebody who's
familiar with Indian companies to at
least try to think about why tataa
Consulting Services might be less
affected by cross-holdings than others
yeah I'm sorry it's
what service versus production I think
that's part of it but there's how old is
TCS as a company maybe 30 35 30 it's a
Outsourcing company right how old is T
Steel T Motors I think Tata steel might
be the original Tata company right 100
plus years old you saying what's age got
to do with it almost everything until
the 1970s or early 80s most of these
companies were privately owned by the
Tata
family so if tart steel had a bad year
and tart Motors had a good year what did
they do they took money they owned all
the companies anyway they took the money
out of tart Motors put into tart steel
and they give they gave them at least
technically shares in tart steel these
cross Holdings are a reflection of
history and the older a company is the
more history streets caring with it TCS
is the youngest of the four companies it
and it came into being after the other
companies had become public it's at less
of a burden of carrying this cross
company investment that the other
companies have so if you look at Samsung
and you look across the Samsung group
you'll find that the oldest parts of
Samsung have a much bigger cross-holding
problem than the youngest companies do
but it is what it is you can I mean you
got to Value these companies with the
cross Holdings doing the best you can
finally truncation risk not unique to
just Emerging Market companies now but
but with Emerging Market companies it
can be a much bigger issue because it
can come from multiple places it can
come from natural disasters I remember
doing evaluation seminar in Antigua why
did I go to Antigua it's a very cold
winter in New York and they said can you
come and do a valuation seminar I said
what's the temperature today and they
told me and I said I'll come out right
away so I do the valuation seminar I do
a typical cash flow discount rate and
almost everybody in the audience is an
antig and business person and what's the
biggest business in
Antiga it's
tourism and what's the biggest risk you
face a
hurricane so all through they're talking
about betas is I don't care about betas
I don't care about but what do I do for
Hurricane hits how do I bring that into
value you saying insure yourself that
could be almost all of your value if you
insure yourself so many of them are
uninsured this became the big risk you
had to incorporate it it's it's a
discrete risk so farther way terrorism
risk parts of the Middle East especially
I mean there was an Egyptian five-star
expensive hotel that I think got wiped
out by terrorism has never been
rebuilt or it could be nationalization
risk student of mine who lives and works
in Venezuela called me a couple of years
ago and he says my business is doing
very well and I said that's good right
he said I'm scared said what the
government has noticed that I'm doing
really well I said that's good right he
said no because they might want it
nationalization risk he said how do I
incorporate that into my valuation
notice in all three what do you have in
common a discrete risk
right and if that happens your value is
going to be very different I'm going to
adopt the same process I adopted with
distress risk when there's a discret
risk I'm going to keep it aside while I
do my valuation because it's distraction
value the company as if that risk didn't
exist and then bring in the likelihood
of a hurricane terrorism or
nationalization to deal with it so I'm
going to give you an example and this is
a kind of offbeat
example aramco everybody familiar with
aramco but if you telling a story about
aramco what would it
be 300 million barrels of oil under the
sand where you stick your finger in oil
comes out of the ground it cost you
almost nothing to get the oil out it is
the easiest of all stories to tell
right aramco of course for the longest
time has been owned by the Saudi
government but about 6 years ago 5 years
ago they decided to go public the day
they went public for a brief moment they
were the highest market cap company in
the
world why 300 million barrels of oil
costing you $6 a barrel so valued aramco
based on expected cash flows and it's a
cash
machine right because you get the oil
out you sell the oil it cost you very
little and I valued it initially using
put free cash for Equity model so you
know why not free cash for the firm debt
with Middle Eastern companies is kind of
a touchy area to begin with the ramco
doesn't use much debt so I said I'm
going to stay Equity focused I projected
out the free cash equity for the next 50
years I think I talked a little bit
about this in the context of terminal
value I didn't even see the point of a
terminal value here because once you get
the oil out of the ground what do you
have the Saudi Sands I don't think
anybody's paying you for those sand so
the terminal value is nothing I just
take the oil out I take the present
value of the oil cutting a long story
short if you take the present value of
that oil discounting B at a cost of
equity of a mature Oil Company the value
you get is about
1.6 billion depending on which model you
use free cash for the firm free cash Ro
Equity so that was my initial try try
the IPO valuation because they filed a
prospectus no came up with the value 1.6
billion but then I said am I really
buying a company when I buy aramco or am
I buying a
country aramco is 80% of the Saudi
budget the cash flows from aramco Loan
in effect I'm buying essentially a
country and then I stopped am I buying a
country or am I buying a piece of the
royal family it's all connected here
right and then I started to get worried
about my 1.6 billion because what am I
doing I'm making a joint bet on the
company the country and a royal family
staying intact for the next 50 years and
this is the Middle
East I'm not making any political
prognostications I don't want tweets
going out from here saying the modin
predict
Saudi royal family fall I'm not making
the Judgment but if you're looking at 50
years there is a chance it's
nonzero that change could
come and if that change comes what
happen I don't think they're going to
nationalize a ramco but when
nationalistic governments come in you
know what the devices for extracting
value from a Oil Company especially if
it's publicly Cre what do they
do they raise royalty rates basically
right Dividends are actually coming out
of the cash roads everybody gets it you
raise royalty rates because remember you
have to pay the government it's in the
Saudi Sands you effectively make the
company less
valuable and you make your you know
you're giving up value value in your
Equity but you're collecting the cash
flow as
upfront so here's what I did I estimated
a property of 20% that's sometime in the
next 50 years change will come to Saudi
Arabia and if that change comes my my
ramco value is going to be half of what
I estimat so I to looked at what had
happened in Venezuela after then you
know they came into power and how much
the royalty rates went up I reduced the
value of the company by a half I took an
expected value so by now you see the
pattern anytime you have a discrete risk
you attach a probability to it happening
and ask yourself What Will My Equity be
worth if it happens your big risk in
aramco has nothing to do with oil prices
cash flows it's got everything to do
with that political component that is
implicit about what will happen to
aramco if things change in the
ground talk about valuing backs yeah
that's a good question I didn't even try
the 20% is already a number that I
plucked out of thin air right so I know
going deeper than that you're going to
end up in a in a in a mess of politics
that you don't want to deal with so as
long as I bring in some number greater
than you're right it matters whether it
happens in year 49 or year three if it
happens in year 49 I'm much less exposed
but then the oil is out of the ground
right so it does matter when you know
when it happens and that value that you
see should be an expected value across
all of those
outcomes which brings me to valuing
Banks do you remember what I said about
what I used to start every Bank chapter
with valuing banks is easy right so let
me go back and justify why I said that
uh it was based on two assumptions I
used to make about Banks before 2008 the
first is I assume that Banks were run by
sensible
people and the second I assume that the
people who regulated Banks knew what
they were doing that they would keep
Banks from doing really stupid things
that was incredibly naive
right and what brought them home to me
2008 what did we discover in 2008 that
regulatory overlay on banks was full of
hes and second we found that Banks were
run by some of the least sensible people
on the face of the
Earth the days of Innocence are gone so
I want to talk about how I used to Value
Banks first
when I trusted managers and trusted
Regulators why that doesn't work anymore
and how I value Banks now so let's start
with a traditional way in which we used
to Value Banks before 2008 so the
dividend discount model you see why when
you use a dividend discount model you're
trusting
managers because then you're saying
Banks pay out what they can afford to
pay out they're not paying out too much
or too little you see why Regulators
become part of the game game because
you're assuming Bank Dividends are not
risky because Regulators will keep Banks
from doing stupid things or risky things
so with those two
assumptions use the dividend discount
model so here's an example of an
Egyptian bank it's called CIB Egypt it's
a Well regarded well established Bank
reinvests about 75% of its earnings back
has a return Equity of 42% and
everything is done in Egyptian pounds
before you get too impressed by the high
numbers the risk free rate was 10 .53 so
it's a higher inflation currency higher
inflation returns it's a good bank it
earns a great return Why does it earn
great return because in Egypt foreign
banks are not allowed to enter the
Egyptian business market so they have
this Market themselves they can charge
companies above Market rates and get
away with it because the companies have
no choice so bunch of factors playing
strong competitive advantages I did
assume that over time the competitive
advantages would get lesser if not fade
so over time as you see my growth rate
decrease my payout ratio goes up and my
cash flows reflect so basically I'm
estimating expected dividend by starting
with earnings and estimating a payout
ratio a cash flows Equity right I
discount them back at a cost of equity
and I do bring in country R so I'm not
being unrealistic I start with the
Egyptian pound risk free rate and if you
remember that's something we talked
about in the context of estimating risk
free rates where I did not have a
government bond rate so I took the T
bond rate and adjusted for the expected
inflation
I did bring in the beta for banks you're
saying it's an Egyptian Bank wait I will
punish the bank for being Egyptian but
not through the beta but through an
equity risk premium of 15.7% so I'm
charging a high Equity risk premium
translates into a high cost of equity
but I'm still earning well above the
cost of equity at a 42% return Equity
what I get as a value per value per
share was about
42 the stock was trading at 36 and don't
even dare ask me the question did I buy
actually tried you know how difficult it
is to buy an Egyptian bank I couldn't
find it on my brokerage account I to I
actually have to go through an Egyptian
broker I'm not even sure whether I'm
allowed to buy the
bank but this is a classic dividend
discount model this is I always to Value
every Bank no matter where in the world
and then 2008 hit and there are a couple
of things that I realize very quickly
the first is Banks in particular and
financial service companies in general
are opaque about what they tell you in
their financial statements I'll tell you
what I mean a bank will tell you how
much they made as loans right but
they're actually very bad about telling
you how many of these loans are in
trouble they'll give you some general
bad debt number that but you you're
trusting them you've set aside enough
money to cover your bad
debts they own stuff Financial assets
some are contingent on that so there's a
lot of stuff you don't know and for the
longest time we had this fian bargain
where we accepted it you know why we
accepted it CU The Regulators could look
under the numbers and make sure there
wasn't truly bad stuff there The
Regulators come into the game again
we've accepted opaque financials because
we assume The Regulators do their job so
that's the first thing to remember when
you value Bank the numbers don't tell
you very much because you're trusting
Regulators to do the Dirty Work of
protecting you
second when we value regular company if
you remember I've never asked you about
book value why I don't care last year
out of 48,000 publicly traded companies
6,000 had negative Book value for Equity
6,000 companies and didn't bother me the
least you know Home Depot has a negative
Book value of
equity now we can debate how much Home
Depot is worth it's worth like $200
billion but the book value of equity is
negative what do you think made it
negative how does Book value become
negative for a company
for many startups Book value of equity
is often negative for those startups why
did it become
negative we TR what makes Book value of
equity
negative one is you keep losing money at
some point in time you hit zero and you
keep going so startups it's the losses
you've had over your life that drive it
negative but that wasn't the case for
Home Depot so what else do companies do
that can sometimes make the book values
of equity
negative yes
or Buybacks in general right this is a
phenomenon I talked about this
two-thirds of cash flows from us
companies last year came with former
BuyBacks you're saying so what think
through the mechanism of buying back
stock you buy back stock at the current
market price typical us company the
market value of equity is three to four
times the book value of
equity so if you buy back
25% of your Equity are already in
negative territory Home Depot BuyBacks
have pushed the book Equity to negative
territory doesn't bother me I don't care
because I don't even look at book Equity
when I look at valuation of a company
but with banks Book value of equity
matters and here's why all the
regulatory Capital ratios for banks are
built around Book value of equity tier
one tier two tier three they're all
built around Book value of equity and if
your book value of equity becomes
negative you broken several regulatory
Capital barriers The Regulators are
going to show up and shut you
down so here Book value of equity become
comes the key number which also gave me
the opening for thinking about hey now
that I don't trust Banks to pay what
they can how do I estimate the Free Cash
Road Equity you saying why don't you use
a traditional net income plus
depreciation minus capex minus change in
working capital try that for a bank it's
almost impossible to do so here's my
version of free cash equity for a bank I
start with the net income and then I
look at how much you have to reinvest in
regulatory capital and treat that like
capex
so help me out here what will drive how
much that reinvestment regulatory
capital is going to be let me first give
a choice under capitalized versus over
capitalized Banks if you have an under
capitalized bank and you're trying to
Value the bank what do they need to do
to keep going they got to reinvest a lot
in regulatory Capital it lower your free
cash Road equity and give you a lower
value in contrast if you're an over
capitalized Bank you can get the same
growth trade with far little
reinvestment because you already set
aside money for the regulatory Capital
so started this class we talked about
how we reward over Capital this is one
of the places second if you're a high
growth back what does that mean you
going to grow your loans good you have
Ambitions but you have to invest in
regulatory Capital if you're a growth
Bank you have to invest a lot more in
regulatory Capital than if you're a
mature
bank so it allows me to take the
characters of the bank bring them into
my free cash Road Equity so I'm going to
show you valuation of a bank from 2016
it's a bank that I'm sure you've heard
of bank called doche Bank in fact the
blog post I wrote about DOA was a Greek
tragedy at a German bank and I chose my
words deliberately you know how the
Germans think about the Greeks right
they think the Greeks can't run lemonade
stand and basically you know especially
after 2012 they're very but this if you
think about a German institution do bank
is it it's been around 150 years it was
considered the classic German Bank and
the reason I said a Greek tragedy at a
German bank is by
2016 doche Bank looked like somebody
who' had too much to drink and couldn't
find the
door starting in 2008 almost every year
Deutsche had one shock after another
another big loss another billion dollars
another $2 billion so by
2016 Do's regulatory Capital ratios had
dropped well below what safe ratios
would look like and then in 200 16 the
Department of Justice US Department of
Justice assessed a fine of $10 billion
on deutche for something they did in
2018 a delayed reaction but it's a big
you take a company that's already under
capitalized you find it 10 billion think
of what's going to happen to its
capitalization it drops well below DOA
was in trouble in
2016 losing money under
capitalized and I wanted to Value it so
I knew what I had to do first I made its
losses become profits over time I
assumed that it would know would convert
it why because it still had a fairly
healthy Commercial Banking business in
Germany that would make it back and I
wasn't expecting Miracles by the end of
year 10 I thought it could make its cost
of equity so as the return Equity goes
from negative to positive my net income
net income it started as a loss becomes
a net profit so I'm fixing the profit
but I have a bigger problem with
regulatory Capital right I've got to
bring the Reg regulatory Capital ratio
is up and in this case I want to get the
regulatory Capital ratio from
12.41% that is actually the 75th
percentile of all banks if you have
access to Capital IQ for banks you can
actually pull up the T1 Capital ratios
for all banks I said they've got to
become go to the SE because they have an
investment banking arm the capital arms
are good how do I get from 12.4.1 to
15.7 it's going to be painful because
that means each year I've got to
reinvest immense amount especially in
the early years so to
survive do you will have to invest
almost you know 6.5 billion in year one
so each year I estimate what the
reinvestment is going to be bottom line
if you look at the Free Cash Road Equity
I minus 11.7 billion in year one minus
so basically what am I saying here do
will have to go out and issue fresh
Equity just to survive and keep going so
I'm being realistic about what they will
need I discounted them back at a cost of
Equity one of the things I've taken to
doing since 2008 I actually have imputed
cost of equity for banks based on the
regulatory Capital ratios if you're a
risky bank I give you a much higher cost
of equity than if you're a safe bank so
rather than give all banks the same cost
of equity because you can be risky or
safe I give a higher cost of equity I
discounted back the value per share that
I got was
$22.97 even adjusting for the fact that
Deutsche might not make it they' be
taken under regular atory oversight like
the Royal Bank of SC Scotland was in
2009 the stock was trading at about 2060
I'm sorry stock was actually at
$13.33 so you want to ask the question
right did I buy I did buy
do and the first thing they did right
after I bought them was issue $10
billion of new Equity I wasn't surprised
because it's in my cash flows they
issued it it's a rights offering where
people could actually and because of the
rights offering and the stock price
jumped I sold half my shares in the
rights offering which you're allowed to
do which is a good thing because the
other half kind of collapsed again why
because there was another Scandal
another and that's why I described doer
the the story that I give for do is of
that character in the horror
movie you know what I'm talking about
usually it's it's very sexy but usually
it's an 18 or 19y old woman who goes to
a house where the lights are all
gone opens the door and walks in and
there's a door leading to the basement
and there's a sound of a chainsaw come
on if you were a sensible person would
you first walk into a house where
there's no power and no lights and then
once you get to a door with the sound of
a chainsaw would you actually open the
door and go down but this person
actually does that and of course the
rest is blood and gore and the movie
continues don't is like that
character it keeps going to the door
opening going down to the basement oh my
God I didn't think it was going to be
this bloody I will never do that again
two years later go down get bloody again
I am I'm I'm out of do shair know I
don't want this Horror Story repeating
but this is a bank that is a horror
story two years ago when Silicon Valley
Bank kind
of Unwound in a
hurry I actually valued City group what
do you think of city as a
bank it's a boring bad bank and there's
no exit hatch here so any of you have
jobs at City don't retract it's fine you
they'll still pay you it's just boring
because this is there's no high growth
here right it's a bad bank because it
earns about 2% less than its cost of
equity never will catch up just locked
into a bad
business they'll survive they'll be you
know you know what the one thing they
have going for them is a lot of old
depositors and that's a good thing CU
what caus Silicon Valley Bank to unwind
so quickly young people connected to
each other online right because the
rumors about Silicon Valley started on
Wednesday by Thursday the bank was
bankrupt because so many people withdrew
it people in
City they they don't even look I guess
at the newspaper so basically their
accounts been with City for 50 years
when which is not unusual if you think
of you know talk to your parents and you
ask what bank you're at the same bank
that they were 20 years ago it's nice to
have old customers who are never on
Twitter because no rumor ever spreads
fast enough for them to
overreact so I you know I valued City at
about 60 something dollars per share
using the same approach the good thing
about city is they are over capitalized
so a bad bank with are over capitalized
and I brought that in stock was trading
at like $45 at the same time I valued JP
Morgan Chase much better Bank earns a
17.5% return
Equity but guess which one ended up in
my portfolio City or JP
Morgan City because even though it's a
bad Bank the price was well below the
value JP Morgan is a great bank but the
price was above the value it's a point I
made before but good companies are not
always good Investments because the
price is that dividing line so some of
you are valuing great companies and
you're going to be disappointed that
they're
overvalued but remember the price is
that driver some of you are valuing
terrible companies and you might find
them cheap it's undervalued and you know
it's because investing in looking at a
business the quality of business is two
different
judgments and finally not all financial
service companies are created alike we
live in a world now with fintech right
fintech is now the you know it's not as
big a thing as it was 5 years ago but
have a different kinds of companies so
if you're not valuing a bank you saying
what do I do you might be valuing a
mutual fund company you might value a
payment processor you got to start with
how this company makes
money I'm going to show you my valuation
of a company called
paytm which is an Indian Payment
Processing Company a company I got
horribly wrong in my valuation I'll talk
about what I
missed but I want to step back and think
about how a payment processing company
makes money
this isn't a new phenomenon right M all
credit card companies are payment
processing companies how do MasterCard
in American Express make
money yeah so you go in you use your
Master Card of visa for a transaction so
you pay
something but that goes to the merchant
right it's not even a transaction it's
called a take rate every time you use a
Master Card or VISA there's a take rate
of 2 to 3% American Express it's 4%
which is the reason fewer merchants
accept American Express and the other
cards because of bigger slice 2 to
3% that's why companies are sensible you
should expect to see cash discounts or
views when more but they're too lazy
there's there is this two to 3% effect
so it's all about transactions on your
platform and take rates so about three
years ago this company called PTM goes
public it's a online Payment Processing
Company very much like PayPal but direct
of the Indian market what's a big
advantage of serving the Indian market
all the numbers get much bigger right
the number of people on your platform
PTM at 330 million people on its
platform mind-blowingly high
number and went to Market with a whole
lot of optimism and I looked at them and
when I looked at them what I saw was a
company that a lot of customers on its
platform a lot of
transactions happening on the platform
but a singular weakness which is their
take rate was
79% so remember what I said it was for
PayPal 2 and a half% MasterCard Visa 3%
American expresses 4% they were at
79% I made an assumption a bad one that
this was because of were focused on
getting more people on their platform
and that once now that they had the
numbers and they were a public company
they would turn their attention so if
you looking at the company they already
have 330 million people on what should
he be focused on increasing that take
rate right because you can increase the
take rate you're going to be valuable so
in my story I did assume that the take
rate go from 79% to 2% lower than PayPal
and the other companies but they said no
it's going to be a lower take rate I
came up with the value of about 2,200
rupees per share stocks now trading at
like 500 rupees per share
so I went back and took a look at what
I'd missed in fact one of the mistakes I
made while I was Ring PTM is I
downloaded the app on my phone because I
wanted to see what they did it was a
mistake because every day I started
getting like 10 messages from PTM
offering me free things so now I see why
you have 330 million people you're
giving away all kinds of stuff for free
but the one thing that I missed was and
actually two things one was the
management that that that ran the
company at the time public seems to have
completely missed the fact that a
payment processing company makes money
from the take rate not from the number
of people on the
platform so they've been focused on
making 330 million to 400 400 to 500
million the take rate is actually
decreased rather than gone up that's a
wrong direction the second is and this I
should have factored
in in India there's actually a free
Payment Processing system called
UPI which means me that for you know if
you go buy something and on a roadside
stand you use UPI there's no cost to the
transaction it's not for every Merchant
but you're competing against a free
payment that's going to keep the take
rate low as well so if you take the patm
valuation you keep the take rate at half
a percent 0.5 or 4% the company
basically dies because without the take
rate so if you're valuing a Payment
Processing Company like PayPal what are
the things you're focused on what are
the transactions or ven more you can
take any of those you're focused on
transactions on the platform you want a
lot but you also want to check to see
how much they keeping as a take rate
because often they go for more
transaction volume by cutting the take
rate and you got to be careful you
haven't given up too much to get more
volume
yeah well at that time it looked like
they were going to make money right and
there there was another reason why the
property failure was too low you know
the biggest investors in PTM were at the
time it went public mostly you know
bench of capital firms in Singapore and
China with Deep Pockets and once those
firms take you public they want to keep
you afloat because if you get wiped out
they got to take a right down almost a
too big to fail and the investors here
don't want you to fail you're going to
be able to go back to them for more
Capital if need
be any questions
finally let's talk about value companies
with intangible assets and we'll see
biggest challenge here is the accounting
doesn't keep up right you have
intangible assets and I look at your
cash flows I'm not sure whether I'm
looking at operating cash flows or
financing cash flows or investing cash
flows they all get mixed up R&D is and
operating expense when I ask you what's
the value of growth if I don't fix the
accounting everything is going to look
amazing until I take a step back and say
hey what is the true return on capital
of the company
with
risk I think one of the issues companies
in tangibles run into is they can't
borrow as much money as companies with
tangibles why because Bankers like to
see stuff before they they lend they
lend insane amounts on a building but
they won't lend insane amounts on a
patent and finally to the extent that
these intangible companies rest on an
intangible if that intangible goes away
the question is what happens to the
company a patent a brand name so I'm
going to take you know the issues you
run into first is
the biggest issue for me with intangible
companies with intangible assets is the
accounting is messed up we spend a lot
of time on why R&D should be a capex so
what it effectively means when I value a
company with a lot of intangible assets
I've got to redo all the accounting as a
first step before I try to Value the
company that's part of the reason we
capitalize r&t and if you remember with
Amgen when you capitalize R&D the Val
the numbers you get are going to be very
different earnings and this was on the
first quiz if you remember the earnings
get restated the invested Capital gets
restated the return on Capital gets
restated with Amin you can see that the
effect on all of those numbers but the
bottom line is what does this do to
value and in the case of Ament when I
capitalize R&D the value goes from
$42.72 to almost
$74 I kind of framed this as a start of
the class question L what is it about
amen that makes capitalizing R&D push up
the value what is it telling me about
Ence
R&D that they're converting into
products products into earnings that
it's effective R&D that it's good R&D I
told you about doing this for MC I did
exactly the same thing I took MC valued
with traditional accounting then
revalued it with capitalized R&D there
the value per share went down so it's
not that capitalizing R&D helps all
companies it'll help companies with the
R&D is good R&D the Investments earn
more than the cost of capital so that's
part of the reason we capitalize R&D is
to separate companies that do R&D well
from the companies that
don't and lastly you
know when you think about intangibles
you know it has to show up somewh
remember the it
proposition if it is going to have value
it's got to show up either in the cash
flows or the discount rates so at least
I'm going to set up this process of
where I can show it if you have
something like you know great management
brand name it's got to show up either
the growth rate the
margins maybe even the risk maybe you
have less risk because you have an
intangible so I'm going to use an
example that some of you might be
familiar
with do any of you own birken stock
sandal you can admit to it it's
okay usually it's older you know B in
stocks Market till it's older and it's
70% women 30 and why do they wear biren
stock because it's stylish no it's
supposed to be comfortable make your
feet Good Sophia do you own
burkenstock and in a sense it has a long
history it's 250 years old as a company
it was a
German shoe maker who founded the
company and for a long time they sold
their shoes to German know companies
that took care of people who had foot
problems and then in the 1960s this
German American Tourist goes back to
Germany for a summer and she has foot PR
she wears burken stock she loves them
and she goes to the owner and she says
can I take these sandals to the United
States I think I can find he was very
resistant he said this is for German
people with foot problems I want to keep
it for German people with foot problems
he said no no I think they will buy it
so reluctantly he let her take the shoes
to the
US and the rest as they say almost
cultural history because those shoes
ended up in a store in La and hippie sto
by and what was the essence of hippie
that you took what people were doing and
you did the exact exact opposite you
wore suits we don't wear suits you wear
shoes no no we wear sandals if you look
at pictures of Woodstock you actually
see people going through mud in their
burkenstock couldn't have been
comfortable but they were sending a
statement to the word I don't wear
shoes we talk about brand name as
something companies work on that's the
start of the Birkenstock brand name it
became the anti-establishment
ship and then it went into hibernation
because hippies became less popular they
and then in 1992 Kate Moss you know Kate
Moss is one of the most famous
16-year-old Kate Moss wears burkenstock
on the cover of vog
magazine and then Birkenstocks take off
on campuses as a
shoe Birkenstock has a brand name it's a
brand name that comes from these
accidents of History where it was in the
right place at the right time and of
course celebrities where burken stalk on
I've seen celebrities on the Oscar stage
wearing Birkenstock and they do it for
nothing in a world where people pay you
know the Jenners and the Kardashians
tens of thousands millions of dollars to
sponsor their product got Birkenstock
having celebrties Steve Jobs were were
birken St in fact his Birkenstock went
an auction a few years ago sold for
250,000 so you got a brand name you got
celebrities wearing your shoes you also
have a management change until 10 years
ago this company was run by the family
then in 2012 they hired these outside
management managers who turned out to be
really good they found a way to preserve
the brand name and connect to there's a
Prada burken stock if you interested you
can go on Google I think it's like
$1,500 it's the burken stock with a
little Prada Insignia on it very clever
way to grow it and then finally the
Barbie movie came out the summer before
Birkenstock went public you saying
what's a Barbie movie got how many of
you saw the Barbie
movie remember why burkenstock is part
of the story right Barbie wears pink
burkenstock in the movie you know birken
stock sales jumped about 30% right after
the movie came out all intangibles right
so I'm going to leave you with this I
actually valued burken stock over the
time of the IPO I'll send you that post
where I decided to take all four
intangibles great management the brand
name the Barbie buzz and the celebrity
advertising and I brought into numbers
and effectively I show you higher growth
rate because of management higher
margins less
reinvestment and ultimately here's the
picture it basically builds up to the
value of burken stock starting with just
being a sandal company and then adding
each intangible on so when you think
about intangibles I want you to be
creative and think about where you
showed in the numbers rather than talk
about it after your valuation by the way
the company has a great brand name I'm
not interested I want you to see it in
your value so I'm going to leave you
with that have a great spring break and
I will see you when you come
back yes
later
so I guess doing income net income
contributable
as
Che
scared the
one they've consistently paid out more
dividends than
intive that's what I meant
bank they not
banks9 knew they were under capitalized
but everybody think you're what kind of
you send
not suain right so that's why
overed the
divid I would also INE share BuyBacks
right and the additional the1 also has
kind of buyback cash keep di you don't
know when to stop and that's basically
why the this when you do the free Equity
you're going to throw some cold water
the whole thing so that dividend you're
paying that's not what
I'm invest because it's a sh coming you
better cut the divid and be proven by
the regulat telling you better cut
dividends but I do include
the repurchases in the so set them equal
to share bubs
you
so
problem's no equation
go with whatever collected dat but
ultim I don't think the budget
cuts move into the I feel might actually
beneficial
replacement for those Val to come in so
I think the budget C story might have
less of a negative impact
on they'll be stepping into the breach
of all these other people now will
be I think that the story says in that
on the commercial side how much they
will grow will be by
the
market the
market market that
whatever breaking
revenu you have the Cho
how are you how are you so uh my name
Isis we're from Arizona so we're
prospective well we
actually uh we're not we yet I think
likely but uh what do you dress for
Arizona it's a cold out right you're
coming shorts in and t-shir right I
don't own many jackets or fans so
get we just we sat through the class we
really L your lecture there question so
over the summer because we have some
time right now we're off how should we
prepare for just like I
guess
life enjoy your summer the last summer
you're going to enjoy in your life next
summer you're going to have a job you're
going to have an
internship take it in come me don't rush
it right I mean keep aware of what's
going on outside don't get don't get all
your skem too much so I think that what
you can do in the summer is
actually because cool off don't keep
inct with what's going on companies and
Market we to watch you
every the rest of the day whatever you
want to do don't do
too too Fus and get
class if you have you take a statistics
class
not really but I you accounting class
you don't have to get
too I'll you
right this is a political judgment not
an economic J so what do it depend on
the Middle
East Syria you people that
you who years you have most experts
always so in Tren you can never
get enough later you wake up you done on
the the guy gone so Middle East that
think there
lots of dumo under the have the Saudis
so far been able to keep control of it
yes but it's no paid country you have no
idea whether in fact there's a lot of
un so the question is this is about the
next years will there be something
happening and I think the answer is
definitely not
zero it's not 100% either because we all
wel give but I think that
is it a high number or low number not
even the 20% it's a high number or low
number and that I think is is a techical
I think that it's a low number because
the Saudis have managed to use money to
kind of build some insulations and kind
of contr quickly the poor country the
ruling hierarchy didn't have that buffer
being able to spread around the larest
that are
almost every citizen essentially is
buffered anded all through their lives
college is PID for PID for that's your
all money and it costly to the Saudi
government but it also brings them this
do you want to really break the system
and have to say to your
own but Qatar and Saudi Arabia it's
essentially but
still
going my my story also the person taking
over is not Isis because Val Z it's some
intermediate
moreal Next
Generation Ben whatever his name is is
very different from the previous
generation in terms of being assertive
about Saudi Arabia right who knows
what so think that this is going to be a
on what's
going but for the moment more acemic
practical because
offering Saud
government and you have to be a citizen
to buy the
shares so it's very very constra it
would be different if it becomes 50% of
the shares in the public market
I think
this take care you use
PTM you're you you're from the US right
you're not you you never use p
okay good to know good question I though
I'm mentioned last class but they have
an interest income interest expense I
originally count like a count that was I
so when you add the cash balance that's
already coming you don't account
forc because when you add the cash
balance that cash balance create
interest if you add the interest income
to your cash flows and you add the cash
the issue I had with it was in the uh in
the credit rating I wanted to synthetic
rating they didn't
have net income interest income interest
income exceed
interested debt is so close to zero give
them a tripa rating we probably get the
same so just give them an investment
rating and on
soin
spree
Rd so myy does
includ but you know that a lot of it is
also tied to stocked
comp
question The Crossings and not operating
assets so my company also includes
called strategic Investments which
includes private and public
deities all those come
under okay and then last question was
the class ination
for what actually thought the revenues
in the Stream they're not lean they're
actually so the growth rates might be le
the Reven are you talking about the
growth it's
AOW because I don't work with
Revenue grow R so whatever
effect doll
ret being machine in 2010 higher revenu
for Amazon they actually deliver what
happened up to 201 that's another retail
company year theal hicup if you five
other new businesses you're going
beond now my end game is not comparing
it to Walmart but Collective value the
largest
compan in your experience is that
typically what
happens talking about talk about Amazon
it's already a special company re so
it's already an exception right can't be
typical
because not too many business companies
can go multiple bu
I kind question yeah um so in your ear
classes you mentioned that when return
on capital is equal to cost of capital
then there's no grow Val no no value at
there's growth but there's no value at
you become a bigger company but the
value will not go up okay I was gonna
ask why why use you you use any growth
rate yeah because and the value would be
the same so that that statement still in
that case what's the
considering the giny spreadsheet that
it towards maturity and in stable growth
it says there are Returns on Capital
should be roughly similar to our cost of
capital that's a default right if you
change it I'll let you set it above if
you set it equal then the growth rate
becomes irrelevant so you can play with
the growth rate it won't have much
there's a timing effect there's a
one-year reinvestment effect there'll be
small effect but what extent then does
it matter that we use the growth rate of
the
economy the capital you put zero get Dr
the same value so then using the the
risk free rate growth rate is only
really useful once we're talking about
talk about growth rate gender is useful
only if you think a company can ear more
than 11
theost question thank
you you're welcome take care
the